we start tonight with the Fox News Alert
tonight we begin our Hannity watch on
the Democrats and their radical agenda
for America Nancy Pelosi has now
officially taken back the gavel and now
the hate Trump Democrats are gearing up
to carry out the agenda they were hiding
all during the election and we are
warning you about they want their crumbs
back they want to eliminate ice open
borders Obamacare on steroids they want
a single-payer system endless endless
endless investigations how does that
help you they want to investigate the
president and of course impeachment
impeachment impeachment with this they
wouldn't tell you so here it is day one
of the new Congress a Democrat
representative has already introduced
articles of impeachment they need to
read the Constitution would be a nice
intellectual exercise for them and the
newly crowned Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi she is refusing to rule out a
plan to impeach President Trump watch
this many Democrats are talking about
impeachment you've said it would be sad
and divisive for the country liberal sue
impeachment are you willing to rule it
out well we have to wait and see what
happens with the Muller report we
shouldn't be impeaching for a political
reason and we shouldn't avoid it
Pietschmann for a political reason so we
just have to see how it comes do you
believe the special counsel should honor
and observe the Department of Justice
guidance that states a sitting president
cannot be indicted I do not think that
that is a conclusive no I do not so you
think it's possible that Special Counsel
Moeller could legally indict a sitting
president let's just see what Muller
does let's spend our time on make
getting results for the American people
as you well know there is long-standing
Department of Justice guidance that
states a sitting president should not be
indicted I thought it is not in the law
and it is not the law everything
indicates that a president can be
indicted after he is no longer president
Oh after he's no longer president oh
okay all these things these trumpeters
wouldn't tell you during the campaign
now they're revealing it we were right
from the beginning and in addition to
impeachment Democrats are also preparing
newly
distillation that demands 10 years of
the president's tax returns that's so
important for your life and you better
believe they plan for a big tax cut
that's probably all imminent there are
no moderates left in the Democratic
Party which is really sad scoop Jackson
more conservative Democrats that want to
get things done for the country coming
together bipartisanship I don't see it
now as it gets pushed further and
further to this extreme radical left
watch what's going to happen we have
incoming socialists Alexandria Acacio
Cortez and Rasheeda Talib there now
joining their fellow comrade Bernie
Sanders in Congress they're planning to
spend a lot of your hard-earned money
single-payer Medicaid for all government
funded higher education for all a green
new deal with massive government funding
for quote renewable clean energy then we
try that Solyndra now they're not just
coming for your crumbs they want the
entire meal but let not your heart be
troubled that's the big news tonight
this is all one big show no bill is
gonna pass without the approval of the
Republican Senate or the Republican
president and thanks to the president's
hard work for the midterm elections
Republicans picked up seats in the
Senate and they have a solid majority oh
and let me make a prediction they will
never ever ever in spite of all their
hopes and prayers and dreams and their
giddiness in their excitement and the
hate Trump media is saying it they're
never going to get 2/3 of the US Senate
to vote to convict Trump on impeachment
never going to happen
so they're wasting America's time and
they're stopping progress still none of
this is stopping House Democrats from
promoting a spending bill that refuses
to fund any part of a wall on our
southern border $0 they were offering
1.6 billion now it's 0 President Trump
is holding the line he's demanding
Democrats why they don't want to bury
her why it's so important and why do
they support it just oh four short years
ago they were all sounding like Donald
Trump you can go to barrier you can call
it whatever you want
but essentially we need protection in
our country we're gonna make it go
the people of our country want it I have
never had so much support as I have in
the last week over my stance for border
security for border control and for
frankly the wall or the barrier without
a wall you cannot have border security
without a very for strong form of
barrier call it what you will but
without a wall you cannot have border
security it won't work you see what's
just been put out on social media where
thousands of people are rushing the
border having a drone fly overhead and I
think nobody knows much more about
technology this type of technology
certainly than I do
having drones and various other form of
sensors they're all fine but they're not
going to stop the problems that this
country has we've never had more people
wanting to come to the United States and
that has to do with the economy and has
to do with a lot of other things where
we're doing great as a country but the
better we do the more people want to
come in here's the truth we all need to
know this is much more than politics
it's all about politics it's also a
matter of national security
the wall is just not some hallowed
campaign tactic it's something that our
own Border Patrol agents are calling for
that they desperately say they want and
need but you don't have to take my word
for it take a step back and listen to
them they're on the front lines I've
been a baurel agent for 21 years I can
personally tell you from the work that I
have done on the southwest border that
physical barriers that walls actually
work you hear a lot of talk from the
expert that you hear a lot of talk that
there are experts that say that walls
don't work I promise you that if you
interview Border Patrol agents they will
tell you that walls work we are all
affected by this shutdown we have skin
in the game
however it comes down to border security
and we're extremely grateful to
President Trump and we fully support
what he is doing to take care of our
nation's borders to take care of the
future of this United States it has
nothing to do with politics
parties you all gotta ask yourself this
question if I come to your home do you
want me to knock on the front door or do
you want me to climb through that window
I just wanna talk about some of those
criminals that Border Patrol agents
apprehend on a daily basis we're talking
about murderers rapists people that
commit very serious crimes in this
country
Isis has been doing an amazing job and
deporting a lot of these people back to
their countries unfortunately once we
deport these people these people will
not stay in their country these criminal
aliens that have been released from jail
that have been deported will come right
back into United States however we had a
physical barrier if we had a wall we
won't be able to stop that
I've been down to the border 13 times
from the Rio Grande to San Diego I've
been in the drug warehouses helicopter
all-terrain vehicle horseback you can
laugh but I was boats on foot I watched
gang members arrested we have the video
are the Democrats going to listen to the
agents are they gonna put the American
people first how many Americans need to
die because we have open borders and
sanctuary city and state policies before
Democrats take this seriously how long
are we going to witness drug trafficking
targeting our kids in small towns and
big cities or the human trafficking or
the infiltration of gangs and even
terrorists that we have identified
trying to cross our border illegally and
get into this country and cause us harm
before the Democrats stop playing
politics four years ago they supported
the Trump policy how many billions of
dollars must you the American taxpayers
spend in deportation fees court costs
health care education the criminal
justice system other social services
before we start controlling immigration
at our southern border I have said this
many many times I am certain 98 99 % of
those people that want to cross the
border into this country they just want
a better life the things we take for
granted freedom opportunity hope for
their kids their grandkids but we just
want to do it legally vet them
big wall big door and that's why in
tonight's Hannity watch on the border
and on the government shutdown we are
calling BS on all of these Democrats
fake attempts to reopen the government
Democrats refuse to listen to the Border
Patrol they refused to listen to a
security briefing yesterday with the
Homeland Security Secretary Kirsten
Nielsen they even refused to negotiate
with the president over the holidays
president Trump stayed in Washington he
didn't go down a moral law go over
Christmas hoping that Democrats would
come over to the White House and
negotiate a deal Nancy Pelosi she was on
a luxurious vacation in beautiful Hawaii
some 12 hours away six hours behind the
time in DC when confronted by NBC News
well she said this about leaving town
for vacation now you had said before the
shutdown that he was being quite
Cavalier and that maybe the shutdown
will give him more time to golf but in
the end it was you that took a holiday
or is it may take the holiday ice
observes the Christmas holiday for a few
days and why cut in fact and cut in half
the time I would have had with my friend
was like a cheap shot but do be fed oh
it's not it's not important it's totally
unimportant
the president may not know this but
Hawaii is part of the United States of
America maybe he doesn't realize that
you know over this past weekend we lost
a police officer his name was officer
Singh this guy was in California and the
sheriff of that County was on this show
last night saying the sanctuary policies
played a big part in what happened
because the murderer was involved in the
criminal justice system was never
deported but speaker Pelosi well the
president was in the white house waiting
to negotiate you were thousands of miles
away lapping it up life of luxury
playing politics with border security
Americans died over the course of that
weekend
Americans an American hero police
officer with a five month old son is no
longer on this earth providing for his
child now this is now day one of the
Pelosi shutdown obviously doesn't care
about daca because the
willing to negotiate Daka he's willing
to talk about dreamers he's willing to
put the safety and security American
people first is she now doing why she's
what she's now doing is this in
America's best interest is this in your
best interest your family's best
interest seems like people only care
about destroying and hating president
Trump and everyone around him hating
Trump is now their singular focus of
every second of every minute of every
hour of every day
and of course Pelosi is not the only
adversary on Capitol Hill on Wednesday
Democratic congressman Hank Johnson
actually compared President Trump and
all of his supporters to Nazis and today
SiriusXM Patriots carry picket ass
Johnson about those hate-filled remarks
and he doubles down take a listen
what I did was compare the times that we
live in to the times that that existed
at the time Hitler gained power I
mentioned the fact that he gained power
democratic elections same way Trump did
our right to speak freedom of the press
due process equal protection of the law
all of those things are threatened by
the current climate of right-wing
extremism now remember this is the same
genius congressman who openly worried
that the island of Guam was going to
capsize and tip over if too many US
military personnel were stationed on the
island they were gonna tip the island
over that actually happened he actually
said that and that's your Democratic
Party now uncontrolled the US House of
Representatives
and of course Democrats aren't the only
people working against the president
even incoming Republican senator Mitt
Romney well he wanted Trump's
endorsement now criticizing Trump in an
op-ed causing many of his Republican
colleagues to resign ly slam the
freshman senator now reporter Kerry
picket also caught up with Romney today
asked him about his rough start on
Capitol Hill take a look the president
endorsed you and now you've made this
outfit how is that not considered
essentially a chip in the back it
certainly
for us to work together on things where
we agree I actually said prior to the
primary in an op-ed that I wrote in the
Utah papers that I would work with the
president of places where we agree that
where we disagreed I'd point that out
that's a great nature of this
representative democracy which is where
we agree we come together where there
are disagreements we express those
openly and honestly that allows people
to have trust in one another and I look
forward to being able to have a trusting
relationship with the President and with
others despite differences from time to
time
all right so 2020 is just around the
corner Romney is going to need to ask
himself well what's better for the
country
the president's pro-growth agenda lower
taxes less regulation oh we are now
energy independent literally that we are
now making more oil oil producing more
oil than Saudi Arabia and Russia we are
for the first time in decades energy
independent does he want originalist
Supreme Court justices does he want
border security or does he want the hate
Trump media to like him or hate Trump
Democrats or the hate Trump deep state
hell-bent on destroying not only the
president but a duly elected president
and his administration
one such Democrat is Elizabeth Warren
has already announced her presidential
bid after saying she wasn't gonna run in
March oh I thought Democrats hate lying
or well not remembering correctly take a
look I hear the president going after
you from time to time referring to you
as Pocahontas and it recently you were
speaking about your Native American
heritage does that get under your skin
when he does that and and do you want to
run for president 2020 I am not running
for president in 2020
I thought Trump aiders didn't like lying
now of course we all know this is
nothing new for Elizabeth Warren today
the president he wasted no time calling
her out for her fraudulent claims of
Native American heritage posting this
tweet mocking Warren's now infamous DNA
test and exposing her life of lies and
even some on the left are coming after
the 20/20 hopeful over the debacle for
example new piece in The Huffington Post
titled Elizabeth Warren's insult to
Native Americans matters even more now
that she's running
they slam her for refusing to stop
publicly claiming her family is part
Native another potential Democratic 2020
hopeful New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
beginning his third term using his
inaugural address to slam president
Trump of course watch this from voting
reforms to roe v-- wade for new york to
protecting a woman's right to choose the
better gun laws to healthcare protection
to legalizing marijuana to protecting
the labor movement to a green new deal
to real criminal justice reform we will
make history and New York will move
forward not by building a wall my
friends but by building new bridges and
building new airports maybe Cuomo should
spend more time focusing on his own
state which is now home to one of the
most corrupt and inefficient governments
in the entire country with New Yorkers
leaving the state in droves moving the
tax havens like Texas and Florida pretty
much a disgrace I'm gonna have a lot
more on that later in the show but it's
time for tonight's Hannity watch on the
deep state our own catherine herridge
reporting House Republicans shuttering
their long-running probes into the FBI
and Justice Department's actions during
the 2016 campaign as they hand over
power but their final findings reveal
FBI divisions over the Clinton case
conflicting claims on rod Rosen Stein's
comments about recording the president
chairman Gowdy chairman Goodlatte even
called for a second special counsel to
investigate decisions made by the DOJ in
the Clinton email and Russia probes and
quote the disparate way these two
investigations were seemingly conducted
now the house investigation also
determined that high-level discussions
were taking place at the FBI and the DOJ
about invoking the 25th amendment and
removing the president that they didn't
want elected in the first place from
office a claim that rod Rosenstein has
adamantly denied and while House
investigations are now over Senator
Lindsey Graham is picking up right where
they left off